There were a few rumors after the break of
day came, whispers that were passed on from
the lips of trader caravans as they traveled
from settlement to settlement. Not many people
would have believed it way back when; it sounded
just like a legend out of an old Western. Too
good to be true. A shadowy stranger wandering the
wasteland, righting wrongs wherever he finds them.
Then, when the job’s done, and innocent people
are safe once more, he walks off into the horizon,
without asking for so much as a ‘thank you’.
Like we said, folks would’ve had a hard
time believing such a fanciful tale… of
course, that was before the Sun started
shining an anomalous light over the world.
Nowadays, people might believe anything.
The earliest days of this strange new world
proved to be a learning experience for SCP-4494.
Otherwise known as The Specter, he was the
physical embodiment of the very notion of fighting
crime. Wherever injustice arose, he would appear
to vanquish those that preyed on the innocent.
While he usually manifested at night, he never
used to have any trouble appearing in the day time
too – in the form of a shadowy figure, wearing
a wide-brimmed hat and a long, flowing coat that
he could alter the length of for added dramatic
flourish. The Specter’s form absorbed almost all
the light from the visible spectrum, but after
day broke, the rules seemed to have changed.
One day, The Specter had emerged to find the
sunlight had become unbearable. Where he had
once been a void of any and all light, he was now
finding it impossible to manifest during daylight.
The moment that the unrelenting light from the Sun
made contact with him, SCP-4494 would dissipate,
yet he kept reappearing at night. It was like he
was being pulled back into existence, and was only
able to remanifest in the moonlight. Despite it
being a reflection of the anomalous sunlight,
that was seemingly enough to negate the effects
it had of preventing SCP-4494 from reappearing.
The same couldn’t be said for any humans caught in
the light though; a far worse fate awaited them.
Even with much of mankind deformed into
creatures that resembled melted wax, there
were still pockets of survivors around. And where
there were human beings, there’d be subsects that
wanted to harm or exploit their fellow man. The
world might have had no governing bodies anymore,
no law and order. But The Specter had realized
that even in a lawless world, his work wasn’t
done. As long as there were survivors of
the break of day, they’d still need saving:
not just from the fleshy hordes of SCP-001-A
roaming the wastes, but saving from each other.
Striding through the remains of the old world in
the dead of night, his long cloak billowed out
behind him. Its shadow almost seemed to blend with
the darkness that surrounded The Specter. But on
the horizon, there was a sight he didn’t often see
these days: light. Not coming from the Sun above,
nor the Moon, but instead, it lay ahead
of him, a fire glowing not too far away.
As he wandered closer, like an outlaw striding
into town, SCP-4494 was presented with the ruins
of a small settlement. Around him, shacks
burned, their boarded-up windows broken to
allow the cursed sunlight in. Everyone that was
still alive normally kept themselves wrapped up
head to toe to block out the Sun, but there were
clothes and protective goggles strewn all around,
a larger pile of garments fuelling a bonfire.
SCP-4494 had witnessed the SCP-001-A creatures
attacking humans, dragging them out into the
light to be transformed into more of the anomalous
abominations. But what had happened here
didn’t seem to be the work of those creatures…
The Specter’s suspicions were confirmed
when he approached the town square,
to find a group of people who had all been
melted into a fleshy mass. The instance of
SCP-001-A paid the crimefighter little mind; it
couldn’t move very far. The few vaguely human
shapes that protruded out of it looked like
they were tethered to poles in the middle of
the settlement. It didn’t take much longer for
SCP-4494 to figure out what had happened here.
Someone had ransacked the settlement, for some
unknown reason. Maybe they wanted something,
maybe they were opportunists just looking to
take advantage of this new post-apocalyptic
world. Or perhaps they just wanted to be
cruel to these settlers. They had broken
the barricades over the windows that blocked out
the sunlight. They had trashed the ramshackle
homesteads that these innocent settlers had
been residing in. As SCP-4494 looked further,
there looked to have been looting too; food
and water, medical supplies and ammunition,
not anything of use to be found. All that was left
was what these raiders hadn’t had any need for.
But as if all that hadn’t been enough, as if
robbing the settlers for what little livelihood
they had left wasn’t enough cruelty, the bandits
had tethered the survivors to poles in the center
of town. They had taken away their protective
gear, and left them at the mercy of the elements.
And as the Sun had crept higher into the sky, and
bathed the captive settlers in its unforgiving
light, they had melted into an SCP-001-A creature.
Turning away from the town, The Specter did his
best to quell his rage. He wandered in the
direction of the next settlement. Something
was drawing him there; he could feel the pull
of the wrongdoers that had left this carnage
in their wake. He’d find them, and they would
pay for what they had done. There was nothing
he could do for their last victims, they
had already been turned by the sunlight.
But if anyone could save the next group of
survivors, it was him. As the wind howled,
the shadowy figure’s cloak flapped in the breeze.
The next settlement looked similar to the last,
although still intact. Shacks built from sheets
of corrugated iron and other scrap metal,
all welded together so that not even as little as
a tiny beam of sunlight could bleed through. As he
stepped towards the boundary of the settlement, a
muzzle flashed, accompanied by the deafening echo
of a gunshot that reverberated all around.
Someone had tried to shoot at The Specter,
narrowly missing, the bullet whizzing past his
head. Not that it would have harmed him anyway.
“Fear not,” he declared. “You can
hold your fire. I mean you no harm.”
“You aren’t with The Slivers?” a
voice called in the nightly dark.
“If you mean the evil doers that left the
last settlement over a smoldering ruin,
then no, I am not,” The Specter replied.
Hearing this, he spotted movement on one
of the shack rooftops. A sharpshooter, carrying
a worn old rifle, stood up, covered in layers of
protection from the transformative effects
of the Sun’s light reflected off the Moon.
“Well, you aren’t dressed like they are, I’ll
give you that,” the sharpshooter called. “Can
barely make you out wearing all those dark
clothes, mister. But if you’re looking to trade,
I’m afraid your timing couldn’t be much worse.”
“Tell me,” replied The Specter bluntly. “The
criminals that terrorized the other
settlement, they’ve been here too?”
“Yessir!” the man answered. “Said
they’d be back tonight too.”
“I have come to help, to do away with those
that would inflict injustice on the innocent,”
SCP-4494 explained in his typically dramatic
cadence. “You called them Slivers, yes?”
“Well, they call themselves that,” the
sharpshooter said. “On the count of their
choice in outfits. They look ridiculous, but
they’ve covered their protective clothing in
slivers of metal and glass. That way they’re
not only protected from the light, but their
clothes reflect it back at other people too.”
“Dastardly villains taking advantage of what
has befallen the Sun,” The Specter cursed the
bandits. “Why are they yet to pillage your
settlement? You said they intended to return?”
“That’s what they threatened earlier! The
lot of them have been ransacking any
settlement that they can’t shakedown.
They showed up here in their stupid sparking
outfits and demanded we hand over half of all
our food, water, and antibiotics. They call
it their ‘Sunshine Tax’. According to them,
if we didn’t meet their demands, they’d destroy
the town. We didn’t know to take them seriously
until we saw the fire over there on the horizon.”
For a moment, The Specter fell silent. His
cloak had slowed, waving gently now the
winds had died down. But in contrast,
his anger had never been higher.
“Who are you anyway, mister?” the
sharpshooter asked. “Never got your name.”
“My name is The Specter, a name these
vagabonds will soon know well. For tonight,
they will pay the price for their crimes.”
“No offense, Mister, uh, Mister Specter,
but look around. World’s gone to hell,
ain’t no justice anymore. What price
are you expecting to make them pay?”
“Simple,” SCP-4494 answered. “The
price is they now have to face me.”
An hour later, the settlement was quiet.
The sharpshooter was still at his post,
scanning the area nearby for signs of
movement. Sure enough, he spotted something:
a group of figures approaching, the moonlight
glinting off their metallic outfits, revealing
their positions as they drew closer and closer
to the makeshift town. The Slivers were coming,
but there would be something else waiting for
them when they made their way into the settlement.
The other settlers were awake, despite how late it
was, wearing their protective layers and peeking
through cracked doors, only to slam them shut
as the glimmering gang crossed the threshold
into their ramshackle home. The Slivers whooped
and jeered, brandishing weapons and threatening
the settlers to show themselves, before the
bandits would break into their shacks and do
to them what they’d done to their neighbors at the
other town. But as one of the Slivers approached
the door of a shack and began pounding his boot
against the metal door, something reached out of
the shadows and grabbed him. In fact, it wasn’t
coming from the shadows: it was the shadows.
Fists shrouded in darkness struck the remorseless
raider. Even with the protective layers covering
his face, the Sliver could feel himself being
bruised by the beating. The Specter struck
once more, knocking the wrongdoer unconscious and
wrenching the reflective metals from his outfit,
shattering them underfoot. The other Slivers
panicked, one drawing a handgun and firing. The
shots were useless, all they did was illuminate
the silhouette of a dark-cloaked figure
walking closer and closer, ready to
make them suffer for their crimes.
It was dusk by the time The Specter had beaten
the group of bandits, stripping them of their
distinctive reflective pieces. Each one of
the Slivers had been beaten into submission,
suffering broken ribs, black eyes, and
missing teeth. With the danger over,
the sharpshooter and the other settlers had
emerged from their hiding places, all eager
to weigh in on how best to punish the bandits.
Many yelled that they should be strung up without
their protective gear, so that the sun melted them
into an SCP-001-A. But The Specter interjected,
urging the settlers not to sink to the level
of the criminals they had been harassed by.
Instead, he turned to the defeated Slivers.
“Turn over half of your food, water, and medical
supplies to these people,” SCP-4494 demanded in a
frighteningly calm voice. “Then leave. Walk into
these wastes and don’t come back.”
The Slivers agreed and fled,
running as fast as they could away from the town.
“Why’d you let them go?” the sharpshooter asked.
“These are uncertain times,” The Specter replied,
noticing the Sun was creeping over the horizon;
it’d be time for him to go soon. “In the face
of hardship, it can be easy to lose our way.
Justice has always been blind; not blinded
by the sunlight, but blind to prevent bias.”
“The Slivers might come back,
though,” the man said, adding,
“If they even survive with what you left ‘em.”
“Maybe they’ll live out there,” SCP-4494
responded. “Then again, perhaps not. But they have
a chance. That is justice, in a time without law,
it is the best we can offer.”
“And if they carry on raiding folks?”
“If they harm others, if they want to waste
the chance they’ve been given, then that is
their choice. But they know, if they refuse to
change, then they will answer to The Specter.”
With that, the shadowy crimefighter walked away
from the settlement. The unforgiving light of
the Sun made him fade as he sauntered off like
an old gunslinger. But he’d be back. As long as
people needed saving, he’d always be back.
Want to own an SCP of your own? Go to
scpswag.com for premium anomalous merchandise!
Now go and check out “SCP-001 WHEN DAY BREAKS”
and “WHEN DAY BREAKS SCP-343”
for more When Day Breaks tales!